this video is brought to you by fabulous
[Music]
what's up everybody michael here now
today we're going to reminisce about the
most convincing fake id of all time you
changed your name to mclovin super bad
now the film was a hit when it graced
theaters and all its horny glory in 2007
and it pretty much holds up to this day
delivering a nice balance of hilarious
moments and painfully authentic teenage
mortification still superbad is not a
film that at first glance inspires
extensive philosophical speculation plus
you know you scratch our backs we'll
scratch yours
well jules the funny thing about my back
is is that it's located on my [__] but
is there something more profound to be
said about two high school seniors
mythic quest to get wasted and bone and
could this stoner flake actually help us
better understand a classic german
philosophical disagreement on the nature
of consciousness you know we're going to
find out in this wisecrack edition on
superbad deep or dumb and of course
major spoilers ahead for the movie
but before i get into it i want to tell
you about this video sponsor fabulous if
you ever have trouble sticking to new
routines or if you're hoping to get a
better grasp on your day-to-day
happiness fabulous is the app for you
it's a digital coach that uses
behavioral science to help you create
and stick to good new habits fabulous
creates a personalized daily routine
that can help you get on track to
achieve goals large and small whether
it's to increase your productivity or
drink more water every day i'm using
fabulous to create a good schedule for
myself because i struggle with balancing
a lot of different things that i want to
do and i think fabulous is going to help
me have a well thought out structure so
i can do all the things i'm excited
about now the app helps you create
rituals throughout the day with small
steps that help you ease these new
habits into your life and can lead to
long lasting changes you can choose
between two approaches on the app habit
tracking or dedicated programs with the
habit tracking approach you can go at
your own pace as you complete bite-sized
tasks and get gentle encouragement
throughout the day you can pick from 100
tasks within the app or add your own
i'm gonna add a couple things in here
right now okay
stop applying to be on american ninja
warrior even though you've never trained
for a day in your life
go with the dedicated programs you're
immersed in a multi-week journey of
guided self-discovery fabulous will send
you inspiring letters with motivational
advice inside and at the end of each
letter you'll choose a positive action
for that week these new positive actions
are added to your daily routine and the
app will send friendly reminders that
help you stick to them and with a
fabulous premium account you can track
an unlimited number of habits and access
all the programs and exercises the app
has to offer join the community of more
than 30 million users around the world
and start building your ideal routine
today the first 100 people who click on
the link in the description will get 25
off their fabulous subscription and now
back to the show now on its face
superbad definitely has all the classic
elements of a dumb team comedy you have
two best friends who are classic
underdog virginal nerds delusionally
pursuing a vision of drunken sextup
glory at a crush's party my older
brother always says like the nastiest
[__] like he called me hyman until i was
12.
seth i want to blow you
and she didn't say that come on the pair
secure an invite to said party by
promising to provide the booze via their
friend's totally realistic fake id as
they pursue these goals they'll
inevitably learn some important lessons
about life friendship and drinking in
moderation and of course they'll
encounter some iconic gross-out comedic
scenarios along the way because that
[__] was just like legally required in
2007. someone peering on my [__] leg
indeed superbad is a coming-of-age
narrative through and through the stoner
cousin of stories like pretty in pink or
call me by your name but if you're a fan
of the movie you may have noticed it
transcends some limitations of the genre
by balancing top-notch humor with
genuine heart i'm really sorry that i
blocked your [__] apology accepted
seriously but is there depth beyond that
to find out we're going to need to look
at an infamous debate between two big
dogs of german idealism hegel and jj
ficta note that idealism is the branch
of philosophy that basically wants to
figure out the ideal structure of both
reality and consciousness i.e how does
the world work how do our minds work and
how do our minds work when they're
figuring out how the world works yeah it
took me years to understand this stuff
you might already know a bit about hegel
as he's one of our favorite all-time
philosophers he's remembered for his
master servant dialectic which truly is
a bad vibes name for a concept if i've
ever heard one for the uninitiated the
dialectic is a form of reasoning that
begins with a contradiction between a
thesis and an antithesis that's
eventually if only momentarily resolved
when they arrive at a synthesis of the
two okay for example you could say that
there is an absolute contradiction
between consuming coffee and falling
asleep if your thesis is needing to
sleep then chugging in espresso is going
to be antithetical to that but a
synthesis would be the development of
something like decaf coffee which allows
you to both chug hot brown bean water
and get a few hours of sleep now hegel's
dialectic of choice was between a
subjective and objective spirit as
outlined in his book the phenomenology
of spirit fittingly for our purposes
hegel intended this book to function as
a sort of philosophical coming-of-age
story about how human consciousness or
how your mind works in this case though
the spirit coming of age is less
concerned about getting to third base
with the hottest girl in ap calculus and
more concerned with understanding itself
and properly relating to its own
internal contradictions still the
parallels between superbad and the
phenomenology of spirit are actually a
lot more substantial than you might
initially assume and considering them
side by side might help us better
understand both tales now hegel's
account of the dialectic is supposed to
show how an independent consciousness
comes to recognize itself as an
individual or as a subjective
consciousness with freedom and
capability an individual who can like do
stuff at the beginning spirit is
self-aware but doesn't realize it is
differentiated from the world this is
because it has never encountered another
conscious being like itself as a result
it has no conception of the fact that
reality might not begin and end with it
it's narcissistic i know imagine a feral
child abandoned in a forest and living
off nature who somehow manages to never
encounter another living conscious being
except for a bear who does fun dance
routines with it but then suddenly
something happens spirit encounters
another being just like itself a being
who can see spirit can recognize spirit
as another conscious being
by whatever extreme coincidence this
being too has never encountered another
creature like itself chaos is about to
ensue you might remember a similar
example from classic evantite jean-paul
sartre who talked about how it feels
when a creep is spying through a
peephole and all of a sudden sees
someone looking back at them calling
their own subjectivity into question you
could loosely describe a suburban high
school like the one in superbed as a
sort of free-for-all of developing
spirits you know a bunch of smelly
narcissistic teens encountering other
smelly narcissistic teens just like
themselves in the cafeteria and
struggling to recognize and understand
one another's consciousness all of this
teenage experimentation with identity
can be read as a bunch of developing
self-consciousnesses trying to figure
out who they are and what the limits of
their freedom and consciousness are also
lots of jerking off so what happens when
two spirits meet according to hegel they
get super defensive and try to kill the
other guy sort of like the insecure
teenager who've used the new kid with
cool hair devin as a threat to his own
identity as the school's number one bad
boy type that's because being perceived
by someone else can be painful realizing
that you're not the only conscious thing
in town makes you feel so insecure that
you gotta take out the other guy to
prove your dominance so basically spirit
sometimes acts like an insecure teenager
each consciousness wants to preserve its
own uniqueness and individuality and
sees violence as the only way of doing
this and so there follows a struggle to
the death you better lawyer up
because i'm not coming back for 30
i'm coming back for everything we see
this less dramatically rendered in the
ongoing struggle between seth and evan
who have each had to deal with the pain
of perceiving one another and being
perceived they both want and don't want
to a represent themselves authentically
to one another and to be perceive one
another's representation accurately this
inevitably results in conflict like how
evan conceals the fact that he's going
to room with fogel at dartmouth because
he rightly thinks it'll make seth
jealous i'll tell you because i think
you're a backstabber and you lied to
your best friend and you only want to
hang out with vogel you just don't care
anymore but hegel's described fight
between two consciousnesses doesn't
actually end in death like two
peacocking 16 year old boys there for
the most part all talk that's because
the winner realizes that it can spare
its opponent and still be recognized as
an individual how by making the defeated
consciousness its servant of course but
this hegel argued is an inherently
unstable relationship it's not just that
the servant is hardly likely to be
satisfied with being forced to do the
master's bidding it's that the master's
consciousness though technically the
strong and independent one is now
entirely dependent on the servant think
back to another classic high school
comedy and the relationship between
katie and regina george in which the new
girl servant soon becomes the protein
bar wielding master over time the master
becomes completely reliant on the
servant to do stuff for them like a rich
kid who moves to college and asks when
the maids will be picking up his laundry
the servant ironically thus becomes
stronger than the master if they ever
realized this they would be able to rise
up and overthrow them and as such things
remain tense
we see a sort of version of this
master-servant relationship between seth
and evan
also
i'll just say it it feels really weird
saying master in 2022 so we're going to
call this the seth evan dialectic from
here on out
seth reads like the dominant partner of
the friendship gratuitously ripping on
evan do you think becca's gonna be
psyched that you brought a bottle of
lube
oh evan thank you for bringing that lube
for my
i never would have been able to handle
your four-inch dip inside my without
that gigantic bottle of blue he's most
comfortable when he's bossing evan
around and asserting his dominance but
we see his domineering nature is
motivated by insecurity he's also
brittle and jealous afraid of losing his
power over evan as they transition into
college and i gotta look over at that
looks like the most fun i've ever seen
in my entire life like most cocky and
brash teen boys all this attempted
dominance is of course just a sign of
his deep insecurity so you're coming to
my pardon there right because it's like
fully on yeah why should i not come this
manifests in his intense irrational
dislike for evan's crush becca that
gives
it's also visible in seth's dismay that
evan is going to room with fogel i
didn't expect this from you evan
not from you
i think that booze
we never should have had to hide our
arrangement while functionally ruling
over evan he's also terrified of being
abandoned by him no i can't i gotta go
meet my counselor i'm picking up my
classes for next year
what so i gotta sit here and eat dessert
alone like i'm stephen glansberg this is
jesse needs evan's deference to feel
fully recognized in his own
consciousness and if evan fails to show
that deference or even just pay him
enough attention seth on some level
knows he'll lose all of his power and
more importantly all of his value as an
individual so how would hegel resolve
this unstable relationship that is to
say how would he reconcile the seth evan
dialectic for hegel the submissive
member of the pair needs to acquire an
object which it can express itself in
relation towards it's like how when your
name is seth rogen and you make a
gorgeous ashtray out of clay for the 73
joint you smoke each day you can see
some of your consciousness manifested
and its trippy patterns unless you
become more aware of your material
ability to impact the world anytime
rogan doubts his own abilities he can
simply look at all of the weed consuming
accessories he's created and think wow
seth you really did all this also this
third thing mediates the relationship
between the dominant and the submissive
partners and makes it so that they're no
longer completely dependent on one
another and there is something of this
and super bad as well
though they're still just kids who can't
really materially impact the world
around them they do indeed discover some
third thing to mediate their
relationship through they're fledgling
romances with becca and jules who we
must say are of course also individual
self-consciousnesses and ones that might
seem to be even more dialectically
developed than seth and evan seth and
evans struggle to get booze which leads
them to crash an adult party and do
minor parkour and major acapella while
running from the cops is ultimately
their quest to actualize that third
thing via each one's romantic
relationship and they spend the whole
film striving to achieve that eventually
by entering this romance evan comes to
realize that he is an independent actor
from seth by establishing these
meaningful relationships with others
evan and seth are not only able to be
less publishly dependent on one another
but also to fully acknowledge their very
real love and friendship
i love you
i love you man
i love you and key to leaving their
puppy dog behavior behind is that they
have recognized their dependence upon
each other they recognize each other's
consciousness and how that consciousness
is essential to their own sense of self
this is where hegel's dialectic can also
be seen as a classical example of the
philosophical concept of recognition
that is the idea that we only become who
we are by being recognized as such by
those around us like through our
relationships with others and what we do
in the world having been fully
recognized by one another for who they
really are seth and evan are now ready
to go off to college as independent
young men they have been liberated from
their codependence through their
relationships with women their
friendship is now no longer
characterized by necessity but by
freedom this means they are able to want
what's best for one another and no
longer seek to hold each other back out
of fear of losing an essential part of
themselves
so already we can see that there's some
genuine depth to the way friendship is
portrayed in superbad but you're
probably wondering did we forget about
fogel aka mclovin's wild adventures with
the world's most incompetent cops
absolutely not and to understand his
absurd storyline we need to return to
the idea of recognition a concept that
hegel did not himself invent that credit
is usually given to his immediate
predecessor jj ficta who hegel was
directly responding to in the
phenomenology of spirit faked his
understanding of recognition is pretty
similar to hegel's he also thinks that
we become who we are by being recognized
as such by others but there's one key
difference hegel as we've seen thinks
that recognition is something that can
only be established through a struggle
but feekta thinks the process of
recognition is actually much more
automatic for ficta one comes to be
recognized as an independent autonomous
individual by being issued a summons
from another free rational being
essentially the summons is a command
which says you're free now act like it
it's like how when you're a little kid
your parents empower you to act like a
human being by teaching you how to say
tie your shoes and then expecting you to
do it on a daily basis
or switch to velcro over time they'll
likely summon you to take on just about
every responsibility of adulthood except
probably paying your own cell phone bill
thanks mom and if you ever kicked me off
the family plan i swear to god you'll
never see me again
figta at one point even refers to this
process of summons as equivalent to
upbringing or to the raising of a child
to the community and he thinks that the
summons to be free is bound to be issued
to anyone just so long as they have a
human body which brings us back to fogel
who experiences this fiction style of
recognition when the cops first see fogo
in the liquor store they know his id is
a fake they know that mclovin is the
unconvincing alias of a nerdy suburban
kid who wants to be a smooth womanizing
player we know you're not 25 man
we're not idiots mclovin yeah
did you know the whole time but they
proceed as if vogel was who he wants to
be regardless they summoned him to be a
chill adult shooting with his grossly
negligent cop buddies and the
extraordinary thing about it is it works
by being treated as if he was a 25 year
old hawaiian organ donor with an air of
danger and away with the ladies vogel
starts to act like it after being
summoned by these goober cops he visibly
gains confidence he even manages to hook
up with a girl one who he had previously
struggled to even talk to uh
it's 10 33.
what in this way fogle 2 experiences an
important sort of initiation into
adulthood learning lessons that he can
use going forward that's even after the
cops reveal the inauthenticity behind
the whole night when they admit they
knew he was just a regular kid you can
kind of see a fiction style of
recognition then as the philosophy of
fake it till you make it notably we
learned that vogel's cop buddies are
also striving for their own kind of
recognition specifically to be seen as
cool cops you know cops can have a fun
time too you know
you know in a way
i think we want it to show ourselves so
i guess you'd never really age out of
needing some good old-fashioned
recognition huh and thanks in advance to
all the hip 21 year olds who don't ask
me whose dad i am when i'm at concerts
it means a lot to my fragile geist so
clearly ficta's account of recognition
helps us make sense of mclovin's wild
ride but the question remains which
style of recognition is more effective
in understanding the development of
consciousness
fictus or hegels and to that end is
fogle's coming of age experience as
effective as evan and seth's
well obviously hegel was biased but he
thought something was missing from
ficta's account that is the whole
struggle part you undergo to achieve
true recognition it's kind of like
saying that you can technically do sex
to yourself but it's probably going to
be a more fulfilling experience if you
do sex with a another freely willing
human consciousness see through their
struggle to reconcile one another's
consciousness evan and seth end the film
as serious independent people
fogle on the other hand ends it by
destroying a cop car he is initiated
into a version of adulthood sure
still he seems imprisoned in a way by
the limitations of his role models who
are by their own admission really not
good role models at all
he's not usually this drunk when he does
this
but i think that could make it more cool
fogle doesn't go through any dialectical
struggle that teaches him to become an
independent person instead he morphs
into a ridiculous fantasy figure mclovin
tight if you're recognized for a fantasy
version of yourself are you really being
recognized at all hegel would probably
say
nah bro but like in german obviously so
in short far from being just silly dumb
fun superbad starts to look like an
actually deep film that manages to stage
one of the most important debates in the
history of german idealism while
averaging approximately two dick jokes a
minute they literally made me stop
eating foods that were shaped like dicks
no hot dogs no popsicles you know how
many foods are shaped like dicks the
best kinds
by juxtaposing the stories of evan and
seth and fogel mclovin superbad actually
shows us why hegel's account of
recognition might be superior to figda's
in this way we see that we all could use
a little dialectical struggle of our own
to grow into truly independent conscious
people but what do you think is superbad
a successful illustration of a tricky
philosophical topic or its competing
coming-of-age narratives enough to make
it deep despite all the talk about
bodily fluids and is hegel really better
than figta anyway let us know in the
comments big thanks to our patrons for
recognizing
our consciousness and be sure to check
out all the cool new perks on our
revamped patreon page also don't forget
to check out our new stream wisecrack
live happens right here every thursday
at 11am pacific set fire to that
subscribe button like it's a cop car and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you